après dix ans d'absence laurent gbagbo
est bien de retour en côte d'ivoire
l'ancien chef de l'état entre 2000 et
2011 était à abidjan pour le lancement
de son nouveau parti le point avec notre
correspondante sur place lui la femme
ozouf
une renaissance un nouveau départ le
retour dans la vie politique digne fils
de la côte d'ivoire c'est ce que nous
disent les partisans de laurent gbagbo
qui sont arrivés pour certains dès
l'aube ici à l'hôtel ivoire ils nous ont
confié qu'ils attendaient ce moment
depuis très longtemps et yann très
longtemps que j'attends qu'il tenait et
aujourd'hui j'ai su qu'il est là il faut
que je le croise cepsa jeu simon jenny
habillant il l'avait laissée là il est
venu il va prendre la lutte l'amiral et
s'est montré le combat et avec tout le
monde y avait toutes les appliquer
c'est ça le combat général nous en avons
un peu ma de la pollution d'une
hypothèse soit 2 régionale et de
l'ethnicité de tout ce qui est à bourg
et donc nous nous inspirons changement
complètement voilà avec tout ce qu'il a
appris comme expérience de la politique
mais surtout ces dix années passées à la
haine certains manquent hélas plus le
temps de renforts muet réfléchi et
nous apporter de bonnes idées de bonne
composition et de bonnes directives la
nouvelle loi la nouvelle formation ne le
rende gbagbo devrait s'appeler le parti
des peuples africains côte d'ivoire en
abrégé d'été à c y et se veut aussi
résolument panafricaine dans un pays où
la vie politique est dominée par le rhdp
au pouvoir depuis au moins dix ans les
partisans de laurent gbagbo voici une
information donnée comme l'occasion de
redonner un nouveau souffle à
l'opposition cela pourrait effectivement
aidé à fédérer la gauche puisque le
parti invite les autres à venir
ce se met dans le moule du nouveau parti
qui a aussi des visées
panafricaniste ça peut ça pourrait ça
pourrait booster la vie politique en
général à partir du moment où il décide
de mettre en place un nouvel instrument
ça devient donc évidemment est
naturellement un nouveau départ pour
toute la gauche ivoirienne donc on peut
le dire ainsi c'est un nouveau départ
pour la gauche et un départ qui occupe
beaucoup d'espoir aux lendemains
meilleurs bien entendu et pourquoi pas
vous le retour de la gauche au pouvoir
dans les années qui arrivent alors une
présence qui est déjà très commentée ici
c'est celle d'adama bictogo le directeur
exécutif du rassemblement des
houphouétistes pour la démocratie et la
paix donc le rhdp qui est ici et qui est
là pour représenter le président
alassane ouattara je pense que plus que
jamais nos populations ont besoin
qu'en plus du développement économique
que nous puissions leur offrir une
nation forte forte de sa diversité mais
forte de sa stabilité et cela passe donc
par le raffermissement des liens que
nous avons entre les deux présidents un
an après la réélection d'alassane
ouattara à la présidence de la côte
d'ivoire ce congrès marque une nouvelle
étape dans la recomposition politique
qui semble s'opérer dans le pays depuis
le retour de laurent gbagbo avec en
ligne de mire la présidentielle de 2025